self-assembly is about how independent
parts come together on their own to
build precise things I'm Skylar Tibbits
and I'm the director of the
self-assembly lab at MIT we want
materials to be a new medium to make
decisions potentially be intelligent
reconfigure change our lives materials
that have robot like things but with no
robots we tend to use large-scale
abundant readily available materials
like plastics foams metals we program
our materials based on the response to
energy we use moisture but you can
imagine in the future use heat use light
current many other energy sources so we
take a strip of wire metal and we mold
it into a shape we program the metal and
the structure of the metal to remember
that shape I'm dumping in 180 degree
Fahrenheit water and then I take this
wire and I'll dip it in water and then
it'll transform completely on its own
into this very precise spirograph shape
and it's completely repeatable
in this project there's two materials
there's a black material and a white
material that are printed and we print
with these very precise materials in
very precise places so it folds from a
flexible record like shape into a rigid
saddle like shape so you can imagine
these materials self fold into shoes
into garments into components for planes
into tires that change grip where the
materials are smarter and they actuate
themselves this prototype when you push
down it bulges showing how a pipe could
expand based on capacity and then you
can imagine pipes that shrink to change
flow rate so they pinch where they
undulate in the future we hope that I
wouldn't need to actually change this
through force and it could adapt
completely on its own we're always
excited about doing things that are
seemingly impossible we're pushing the
limit if it seems like we can't let's
try to do it